uh yeah this one looking very one-sided  traffic right now  magnus all he needs to do bring the  black brook into the game back and  i can't even see a move for white at  this point oh you'll stop on the c file  and then it's over yeah you're right  once it's just and then he's going to  step up with the king or something quite  soon  yes that's i think this is uh  it's not very good for for  that there's still some kind of tricks  you know maybe there's the possibility  of white playing bishop takes pawn so i  like your move of just going stepping up  with the king  that's a very magnus move uh stepping  forward with the black king just  covering everything defending everything  but instead magnus grabs another pawn  he's actually three pawns up and  we've just seen duda resign i think we  have magnus takes the win wow  with the white pieces in game two young  christopher duda loses to world champ